c'est un engagement pris par ali rabais
et la liste pour que tu rappes respire
le retour à la semaine des quatre jours
pour la rentrée 2020 une annonce suite à
un référendum auprès des trappistes sur
les rythmes scolaires
on a organisé un référendum pendant
trois semaines nous sommes allés au
contact des habitants dans les marchés
chez l'habitant dans les gares dans les
écoles également et on a recueilli plus
de mille votants ce qui est vraiment
très impressionnant et qui montre que
les trappistes ont envie de donner leur
avis à près de 80% les trappistes ont
décidé de revenir à la semaine de quatre
jours pour ce sixième rendez vous de
campagne ali rabais a présenté son
projet éducation une méthode de travail
avec les directeurs d'école enseignants
et parents d'élèves des mesures
concrètes comme la réduction des tarifs
de la cantine ou la modification des
temps périscolaires attrape plus
qu'ailleurs
nous avons besoin que les enfants quand
ils rentrent de l'école puisse avoir
fait leur travail en étant encadrés par
des professionnels parce que les parents
n'ont pas toujours le temps à la maison
où les compétences pour accompagner
leurs enfants pour préparer sereinement
la journée du lendemain pour donner le
goût de l'école aux enfants
au delà des apprentissages académiques
sur le temps périscolaire nous
travaillerons avec les enseignants
volontaires salariées par la ville
évidemment à développer des ateliers
ludiques et pédagogiques pour les
enfants
autre sujet d'actualité au coeur de
cette réunion publique l'avenir du
collège gustave courbet avec un projet
de démolition pour créer un collège
innovants et j'habite à côté du collège
courbet entre autres dont je suis au
courant de cette future démolition du
collège je trouve ça intolérable ali
rabais sont engagés dès le début de sa
campagne contre le tout projet de
collège innovants dont on ne sait pas
trop ce que ça veut dire
ce soir il a réaffirmé cette position
candidat de la gauche unie la liste pour
que tu rappes respirer soutenu par le
mouvement génération point s europe
ecologie les verts et le parti
communiste français